i wanted to let you know that here at
the pinal county sheriff's office we do
not mandate the vaccine and as long as
i'm your sheriff we will never mandate
the vaccine we believe that your health
choices are yours and yours alone so
whether you get the vaccine or don't get
the vaccine that's your private
information
here we believe in america and freedom
that is pinal county arizona sheriff
mark lamb saying no vaccine mandates are
coming to his department in a video that
has gone viral sheriff lamb joins us now
with more on his message on personal
freedom and the response that he's
getting good morning to you sheriff
good morning ainsley good morning
thanks for being home with us you got so
many views more than 65 000 at our last
check were you surprised
no we kind of knew this would go viral i
mean it's
it's uh it's a hot topic in this country
and look i i frankly i did it because
i'm tired of seeing weak leadership
across this country and weak leadership
as it relates to protecting their
employees rights um so we wanted to do
something that let people know that here
we don't tolerate that well the biden
administration is pushing businesses to
mandate this why are you against it
well i think it's people's personal
choice you know
health choices have always been you know
last year
it was like pulling teeth to get a list
of anybody that had cobot so that when
my deputies responded to their houses we
knew who they were now
these same people are more than willing
to give up all of your public health
privacy uh for the sake of security and
i'm not okay with that i don't think it
should change have you gotten a lot of
support
oh i've gotten a ton of support
you know you get your pushback too i
some news thing called me a rebel but i
don't know i guess that's a good thing
well also in arizona we reported on this
yesterday border patrol agents caught
these migrants that were attempting to
enter the united states in this fake
border patrol vehicle and the driver was
wearing a fake cbp uniform there's a
picture of the car that they were
driving looks very real to the to most
of us but i guess if you're in law
enforcement you recognize it's not real
what what other details do you know
about this
well they do this all the time these
look this is a billion billion dollar
industry of bringing drugs and humans
into this country they they will exhaust
every resource to try to bring them in
here undetected
this is not the first time they've used
they've painted a truck to look like a
border patrol truck this is why as
sheriffs we're standing together because
the federal government's not doing it
we're standing together under protect
america now to protect america from bad
things uh bad policies to protect the
people's constitutional rights and
hopefully your listeners will check it
out at
protectamericannow.com and come support
us sheriff lamb thank you so much for
being on with us
thank you for your welcome thank you for
your service god bless you out there god
bless you too thank you hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now